yeah speaking of foolish penny Brewers
president independence woman's voice
she's not foolish at all and she joins
us tonight so occasionally Tammy as you
know we like to just things are moving
so fast here in Washington it's good to
just pause and remember what the world
looked like six months ago
yes people were touting this man as the
woman's candidate oh boy
yeah the only thing missing from mr. a
vanadis lineup there is that he hasn't
eaten dirt yet I mean maybe he can add
that in and he's still a little bit of
that from from Robert Francis he's got
some time look what I really enjoyed
what was very important about your
initial coverage of this a fool was the
fact that he appeared to be exploiting
one of his clients started annuals right
is that he was making money from her and
she was reduced to doing tours of strip
clubs in the process of him representing
her and that that's what it spoke to it
spoke to issues was he he he did and I
said that to him and I've always felt
sorry for her I've never doubted most of
her story just your record I'm not
embarrassed to say that right and I feel
bad for her and I said that to him and
he said that her stripping in some sad
Club in Richmond Virginia was an act of
female empowerment he actually said that
yes yeah well obviously not you know
when you're seven years old yeah we show
me a seven-year-old who says when I grow
up I want to be stripping at some clubs
you know on a rural road in in Virginia
no girl says that that's not what we
aspire to miss Daniels has an
opportunity to remake herself she's had
problems with him as well and look if if
all of the charges against him are true
this guy is like the Zelig of criminals
I mean he's like trying he's trying to
adjust or would seem to be involved in
so many different kinds of behaviors and
and and crime but it could be explained
by comment he made to the view that they
asked him inexplicably somehow it moved
into what his sexual fantasies were and
he said they all involved handcuffs so
now it looks like he's gotten one part
of his dream fulfilled we always get
what we want in the end don't we a
parent you do you just watch out for
what you wish for because you just might
get it
the Zelig of adapted to everything
around him and this fellow seems to be
competition with somebody but it's it
look for all of us I just wish that this
would maybe he would have been the
perfect Democratic candidate only if all
of this then came out in the spring of
2020 it would have been even better it
would be it would be unbelievable I'm
stealing that line Tami oh great to see
you tonight thank you sir